I'm here to present the first award of
the evening the category is Best Actress
in a supporting role and the nominees
are Joan Judy Davis in husbands and
wives Joan Plowright in enchanted April
Nessa Redgrave in Howards End
miranda Richardson in damage Marisa
Tomei in my cousin Vinnie
there's one thing I forgot to mention
that is that this is one of the few
times in the history of Academy Awards
that five foreign actresses are up for
the same award for English and one from
Brooklyn and for the best performance by
an actress in a supporting role the
Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes to
Marisa
thank you so much then this is such a
great honor to receive this in this year
when we recognize and celebrate and
honor women of course I owe many many
thanks to the cast and crew of my cousin
Vinnie especially mr. Joe Pesci for his
endless support and great talent and to
the whole circle and the team Susan and
Gina and Scott and Evelyn and Kate
MacGregor Stewart and Francesco Puli az
and my very brave family thank you very
much
you